what if i get it wrong the prime
minister
questioning his maths today but what he
doesn't want to get wrong
is the reopening of schools next week
what is the name of the house
that the bad guy is in
slytherin that's right jonathan we know
some people in slytherin don't we
do indeed we do be under no illusion
this
is the first test of the government's
road map out of lockdown
the students then obviously have to self
administer this so they pop this in
there in their own
mouth at winton community academy in
andover
they're ready for the return of pupils
so ready they'll start
testing them this week meaning everyone
can start on monday
how confident are your staff feeling
about coming back very confident
so we carry our weekly surveys uh with
all the staff and all the parents
and they are saying they're feeling
incredibly confident about returning to
work
and parents are very confident too that
the students are going to return to a
safe environment
new research confirms schools are as
safe as they can be with teachers having
no
higher risk of infection than other
working adults
the decision to return to full
attendance is based on a balance of risk
protecting our nhs while protecting
students from the harms of missing
education
our decision is evidence-based the
evidence can't rule out a rise in
infections when schools return but it
suggests
this may be minimal bringing children
back into schools does bring risk but
this
is mitigated by the measures schools
have in place
one-way systems front-facing classrooms
all helping reduce the risk
to staff and students most parents are
glad to see
school start and home schooling end
the youngest one he's not learning as
much because he just doesn't have the
concentration span at home
and they're missing out on their social
skills quite like it to go back at
school just saying i can meet my friends
again instead of always being on video
calls i'm more worried about
me catching it than anybody else
catching it i don't want to catch it
from other parents or
if somebody's there and they don't know
they've got it and because i'm
a very vulnerable person and i don't i
don't want to be seriously ill
everyone agrees it's vital children are
back in school
but behind the scenes their return will
be closely monitored
laura bundock sky news andover